what's up everybody especially those of
you outside of the United States of
America criticizing our UFO trials I see
a lot of memes being posted by you wait
are people talking [__] yeah they're
talking [__] oh look at all the UFO
sightings in the last hundred years
they're all in America why would they go
to you that's a great Point what reason
do they have to go to YouTube fish and
chips maybe oh that must be fun I really
doubt The Changing of the Guard oh do
they think they like Cricket wait to do
it yeah I'll go look at the [__] that we
built in Greece thousands of years ago
y'all even built it Alias came down
helped you and now look what you did
[__] it all up they just want to try
21st century [__] in the 21st century
yeah okay
now that being said that UFO trials
complete [__] it really is if you're
not from America shut your mouth aliens
are not interested in you and your
shenanigans